hello everybody i'm jesse waters along
with judge jeanine pirro jessica tarlov
dana perino and greg gutfeld five
o'clock in new york city and this is the
five
[Music]
the biden administration can't stop
lying to the american people about the
border crisis just days after kamala
claimed the border's secure we're
getting more evidence that makes her
look like a total fool
brand new video showing illegal
immigrants in camouflage scaling a
partial wall on the border in arizona
and there have already been more than
two million border encounters so far
this year a record high
at least there's one democrat willing to
bust kamala on her border lie
vice president harris said this weekend
the southern border is quote secure it's
wrong she's dead wrong on that and i
have said this if we don't secure it i
voted every time for the wall but we
need the wall a lot more
but the lying doesn't end there listen
to this outrageous claim from the white
house
we had to to fix something that was
broken especially by the the last
administration the trump administration
which largely just tried to build a wall
an ineffective wall
along the border and couldn't even
finish that in four years were certainly
doing a lot more to secure the border
and could be doing even more if
republicans would stop their obstruction
by the way where are all those liberal
fact checkers on all of that fox news
did some digging and it turns out nearly
every major fact checker has completely
ignored corinne jean-pierre since taking
over for jen saki
dana are they gonna have to
walk back we know they like to walk back
are they going to have to walk back the
border is secure line because that can't
continue for that much longer well maybe
they will after the midterm election
when they lose and you look at the exit
polls and the border is an issue but
like even just take just one issue of
the border when they falsely accused the
mounted uh border police of whipping
migrants
it wasn't true
they they made those guys sit on their
rear ends for over 11 months fake
investigation
they finally released the investigation
says oh yeah actually that didn't happen
did the white house walk that back no do
they apologize to them absolutely not so
that well i don't think that's going to
change i think that what you're seeing
from kamala harris and the white house
press secretary and probably from biden
if he ever does an interview is that
this is a strategic and craven and
desperate move just to basically say not
us it's trump they want to run against
trump they'll try to make that all about
trump but
one of the problems is there are no
reporters on the border
bill mollusion
amongst other fox reporters but bill
millusion is certainly there and he is
very passionate and has all the pictures
all the videos everything he sends all
this out i'll ask him on newsroom
anybody else down there no the only time
they go is if there's something for
example of governor abbott sending
migrants
elsewhere then they'll go to the
bordering cover bit so it's no one this
is crazy bomb illusion put out a tweet
the other day
that showed these guys in camouflage
going over the wall and all of these
responses were saying that
we at fox
set it up
that it was fake so now you have border
deniers
and you do not actually have anybody
talking about things like the fentanyl
crisis for example that would be one
thing where if i were republicans i
would drive that home 300 americans die
a day and they don't talk about it they
have the nerve to say that this is a
this is trump's fault it's unbelievable
to me
no way
fox could set that up i have trouble
ingesting tape
greg
do you think these guys could have saved
money on the camo because you don't need
camouflage you can just waltz right
through yeah dana's right there's nobody
watching and nobody carrying i think
what's her name what's
john pierre john pierre exists to make
kamala look smart
kamala exists to make majorca look smart
and i'm scared of saying that because i
think he might label me a domestic
terrorist for being insensitive to his
feelings maybe he would feel differently
if the people of the migrants were
posting biden memes that he would be
really really why isn't he considered a
domestic threat by not doing his job by
his own definition right i mean he's
saying that like if you if you post
something online a personal grievance
but what if you're just not doing your
job and allowing terrorists to cross
over that seems to me like a threat but
i got to get i got to be careful but
what you you hit the nail on the head
you get the sense that we do this we've
done these top this story for years you
get the sense that no one's listening
but our audience
and and and i think it's because the
media only cares about the optics if it
can be tethered to republicans or to law
enforcement hence going after the border
patrol agent they could pin that on law
enforcement even though so they didn't
have to say it was biden's fault so the
only way to fix this
is to elect a republican but not for the
right reasons because you know the repub
not because the republicans will fix it
but because the media will then do their
job
when a republican is in charge and there
are migrant drownings and there are 300
fentanyl deaths a day then if they can
pin that on a republican then it's a
story okay because remember remember
what happened to the kids in case cages
how miraculously that went away when
trump went away and how it didn't matter
under obama so uh and lastly i i we have
to stress this because we always get
attacked for being anti-immigrant we're
very pro-immigrant we're against illegal
immigration because both of those
together are very american one
immigration self selects for risk takers
and america is nothing but risk takers
and that's important but what's not
american is line cutting right so that's
and that's the fault of our bureaucrats
but we just don't like people cutting in
line we're pro-immigrant we're against
line cutting that's america
judge i have an idea tell me if i'm off
the wall
abbott hires a child later
abbott hires a child actor puts him in a
cage and the next thing you know the
media all flies down to texas to cover
it yeah oh that's absolutely gonna
absolutely gonna happen you're right but
you know i wanna i wanna start with
something that dana happened and that
that's the issue of fentanyl killing 300
people a day you know dana you don't
have to worry about that anymore you
know why
because president biden decided to
double the penalties for fentanyl
possession the only problem is the rest
of the democrats if they do arrest them
they're letting them out on bail without
bail immediately but look what's going
on in washington right now is that these
people will do and say anything to stay
in power it's all theater it's all
theater they're decimating the border
and i'll tell you how to get attention
on this thing one of the things that
nobody talks about
is how much it's costing us
in the middle of a
recession maybe or certainly it's
40-year high inflation to maintain the 2
million people that are coming through
the border and the estimates now is that
it's 20 billion dollars a year mr and
mrs taxpayer that are coming out of your
pockets for people as we say we'd love
to have other than the fact that they're
cutting in line but you have to fix
something that's broken and for karine
jean-pierre to say you know trump built
an ineffective wall and we're doing a
lot more to secure the border that is an
out and out lie we have never had the
number of people that are coming through
the border as they're coming through
right now and the last thing i'm going
to say is this
every time
we get into a situation where we allow
people to come in legally we find out
who they are
these people we don't know who they are
they don't have to be mass they don't
have to be tested and we don't know who
among them is a criminal they're not all
certainly who's a pedophile who's who's
a thief who's at this anytime we have
two million people there are criminals
in there and nobody is protecting us and
the sanctuary cities are saying you can
all come but i'm going to send you uh
lori lightfoot's going to send him to a
republican area and redistrict which is
now the latest
are we wrong
jessica about any of this
oh yes
definitely continue thank you um
a couple of things greg you said that i
think only our viewers are watching this
and i don't think that's true if you
look at what elected officials the
democratic party are doing in states
like arizona and texas they're hearing
it from people at home there people like
ruben galleo mark kelly did a whole spot
of him building a section of the wall
in yuma
this is something that is penetrating
and as
inflation and the economy becomes less
of a priority issue it's still the
number one issue but there are other
issues that are creeping up important
and importance for the midterms that
includes crime and safety which we'll
talk about later um national security
abortion et cetera and this is certainly
part of that but i think it's just a
general
mispresentation of the issue of securing
our border when this has been an issue
under republicans and democrats we had
the gang of eight right that was split
there republicans and democrats they
couldn't get anything done because the
truth of the matter is is that people in
both states run by both parties
like undocumented labor
and that will continue whether they're
picking grapes in oregon or oranges in
florida and until that stops and it's
not going to stop because these are
hard-working people who do us a great
service they often take jobs that
americans don't want to take and
we're not going to solve this crisis
that way i also want to say something
about the language of all this i don't
think using the term build the wall has
the same scare factor as it used to i
think that democrats have moved past
that if you hate trump you've hated him
for five years now and that that's going
to continue so i do think we need to
move towards a better language of the
way that we talk about these issues
because it's not animating people
in the same way okay so you do agree
with us
thank you i'm glad that that's what you
took away from that hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else